des moines est ce que tu crois péché
originel attend pistone à la rubrique
péché est un péché qui doit être
original parce que je fais tout le temps
et qui est que je ne vends que de moi
tonnes et j'oublie toujours on me dit
alors et le metteur en scène ça devient
honte voyons le metteur en scène de la
pièce et daniel benoin et sa pièce a été
produite à la comédie de saint-etienne
alors il faut le dire c'est le premier
but she oui ah oui ça s'annonçait il
fallait bon maintenant maintenant que je
suis tout bien nettoyer toutefois pas
empêché non c'est pas le péché d'orgueil
c'est le péché des brus centrisme
grosseur peu d'un péché rire s'il
n'avait pas inclus tu sois là ouais
parce que tu pêches par avarice annonça
j'aimerais bien alors là ah qu'est-ce
que j'aimerais bien
après est-ce que tu pêches pas
engouement buzz ah non c'est pas beau
monde c'est bien comme ça pas mal je me
démerde non je suis pas très beau monde
ce que tu pêches par envie on est vite
arrivé je sais pas te le dire tu vas
vite les concurrents fait pas tout les
pauvres non ça m'est arrivé au masters
par exemple s'est alors jetée pêche par
colin rarement un ca faut vraiment non
je suis pas tellement en colère
jusqu'à présent à charles darwin et
shipton parfaite gervais charles
veilleux apparaissent là oui là
il ne s'est pas tu apprends des
monologues du mur parker s'est pas
d'apparaître
si parce que ça j'apprends tout servi
mais non au lâcher tout latéraux fut une
première tout tu vas genre si je peux
éviter mais je sais pas moi de passer
des franches sur la quarantaine de
miettes j'éviterai tu veux ce bien sûr
ah oui tout fait voilà paraître c'est
lui quand je pense que vous avez
toujours dit qu'il est d'accord il a
calé et je n'empêche pas alterner pas
qu'on passe les tongiens donc pas seul
et pouget ce que tu pêches par l'ubs
sûrement d'autres enfin le samedi
est ce que tu crois en dieu dieu
directement dieu non mais alors
effectivement c'est au nom des progrès
de la science puisse qu'il en arrive à
dire que après le big bang lors la façon
dont l'univers s'est créé et organisé ne
peut pas contrairement à ce que croyait
monnier quelques années être le fruit du
hasard
voilà il ya trop de coïncidences c'est à
dire c'est la science qui ramène à
l'idée dieu ou du moins de quel s et
d'où vient cette organisation quoi le
job tu crois diame le nom l'allergie
jamais cru même à l'époque je croyais en
dieu